you've been unfairly wronged by a
brother mm-hmm objectively hmm you
aren't getting the full apology that you
expected the beef is over now and he
treats you well but how do you
psychologically reframe and kill that
lingering resentment unfairly wrong to
hood by a brother interesting brothers
don't wrong brothers we'll start with
that so this dude wasn't actually a bro
a brother met him in umbrella but he
wasn't a brother you make a little
distinction there has that distinction
ever been made before I don't think on
this platform I'm making it cool there's
like hey this guy's my bro it's all good
and then there's like this guy's my
brother my brother is not gonna wronged
me my bro might but my brother's not
gonna wronged me so that he so if it
happens some guy like I said if somebody
that you consider your brother wrong
even that they'd clearly you you
overestimated their really commitment so
here's what's gonna happen to me number
one it's noted noted that's my that's my
ultimate that's my ultimate satisfaction
right when I note when it's it when I
note something yeah
oh it's like oh this is the kind of kind
of person he is noted right now I got
him now I got this person marked so
Trust is not gonna be reestablished for
a long long time if ever mm-hm
right I'm not gonna like this person
clearly but here's the deal all that
mistrust and all that dislike and all
that is gonna be internal I'm gonna keep
it inside because you know what I'm
gonna have those inside I'm gonna harbor
that I'm gonna harbor those things even
this resentment I'm gonna harbor it cuz
I can't I can't just make it go away you
you you wronged me it's gonna be there
yeah but you know what I'm a
professional externally I'm a
professional even if we're not a
business or even if it just like hair I
I trained you just do it
right I'm a professional so I'm not
gonna let his little maneuvers get me
externally worked up about it it's not
happening you don't get control my
emotions like that external you might
control them inside but I won't let you
see that ever so I'm a professional I'm
a normal face that's where I'm coming at
you from just a normal face Hey all good
oh yeah and you know what's interesting
this behavior so when you screw me over
and then I just go okay check noted and
then I don't give you a reason to like
hate me and then you kind of owe me yeah
you know what I mean
so there's that and there's a there's a
fine line like if you screw me over
and then I just allow it to happen and
it was a it was a legitimate violation
well then there might be have to be
repercussions right it sounds like this
did not warrant repercussions mmm
because you know there's certain
situations if somebody wrongs you in
certain ways there has to be
repercussions to me normally most of the
time the repercussions and the best
revenge that you can take is is to
ignore now perform and be successful and
rock on and forget about them and forget
they even exist it that to me is the
best possible way to go because why
would you let somebody interfere why
would you commit any time effort
resources to revenge when I would the
better thing to do is commit those time
resources to energy to success to
winning yeah I'm gonna do that but if
this merits some sort of repercussions
okay then those get carried out and if
those get carried out well then we're
kind of settled but he says you didn't
get the full apology you expected it
sack okay
hey guess what people are arrogant yeah
that's the way it is they don't think
the guy didn't you think he did anything
wrong most likely he's not even
apologizing for it barely so that's what
I do I'm just gonna keep it professional
I'm gonna you're gonna be subconsciously
indebted to me whether you know it or
not yeah
you probably know it you'll probably
feel it because I'm just gonna okay cool
yeah we'll move on but man you know the
thing is this is sort of goes back to
that other kind of topic today like this
guy isn't going around thinking about
you yeah so why are you thinking about
him let's move on man let's move forward
and it seems like a big part of it right
like that it seems like he was he says
you aren't you aren't getting the full
apology you know like remember on that
Seinfeld that apology dude I was talking
to someone I was talking to someone like
a bloody apology I was talking to
someone that we both know whose will say
up a public figure and this individual
was reading YouTube comments and getting
legitimately like emotionally distraught
oh yeah and was was trying to talk to me
about it and like I said man I literally
do not care like I do not care like this
is no factor you don't need to warn me
you don't need to tell me you know what
I need to look out for like I literally
don't care yeah I mean if someone writes
a good YouTube comment good it's funny
that's great if they write in a mean one
cool I find I think those are funny too
yeah I'm not I'm not worried about it
the person that wrote the youtube
comment isn't thinking about me yeah you
know they're not try they're not they're
not reviewing it again yeah and writing
it again and and you know like they
don't care I'm not getting all caught up
in this stuff don't caught up in these
petty things you know I did that we
talked about this on the podcast of the
black belt the black belt doesn't care
about things that don't matter you can
grab the the black belts shoulder of his
gay and he's doesn't care because he
knows that doesn't mean anything there's
no there's no that's no factor so you
wanna that's that's what you want to do
you wanna you don't want to care about
things that don't matter you don't
invest your time and energy things no
matter the guy wrong do you cool noted
you know that he's kind of a kind of a
a devious dude you know that it's noted
cool move on yeah no I'm not worried
about it am I gonna put my trust in him
again
no but that's cool cuz I know other
people to trust yeah let's not get
wrapped around these little things man
let's let's let's let's let's let's rise
above and get some black flag going here
let's rise above I still wonder what
kind of polish quality cut you off so
sorry but yeah and I is the Saint felt
thing it didn't matter the but I'm
wondering one at the same time what you
saying I agree but mm-hmm I do wonder
what kind of apology he got you know cuz
he didn't get the full apology
yeah partial yeah so what partial
apology that can come in many forms yeah
it's probably the most common form of a
partial apology has a butt on it yes
yeah I'm sorry you know I'm sorry we
need to swing by and pick the other two
up the other night but I just didn't
even know that you wanted to come yeah
yeah kind of like it was my fault I'm
sorry but yeah it was partially your
fault kind of thing and then there's the
other one that's like I'm sorry you felt
that way you know you know that one's
worth like hey I'm sorry you felt that
that I was attacking you you know but
you know I didn't mean to kind of thing
where it's kind of like hey you're
because the person doesn't want an
apology for necessarily the actual words
you said it was it was like what you did
mm-hm like you attacked me with whatever
you said you know kind of thing so you
can't just say hey I can't I'm sorry
that's funny is it I start I'm sorry
that you felt that way yeah you know
that is a pretty backhanded sort of yeah
same thing but the but well the one you
say but I'm sorry but you know I didn't
that's kind of like I'm sorry but I'm
not fully like yeah that's the same are
you saying with extreme ownership yeah
that's when people say you know look I'm
in charge of the team and this was
definitely I'm in charge of team when
I'm in charge didn't didn't when things
go wrong it's my fault but I'll tell you
what sorry yeah sorry yeah and my way
from time to time we'll where are no
excuses yeah there's nobody think about
it when you get somebody that actually
believes in extreme ownership there is
their little butts on anything that they
say and strangely I mean kind of I guess
coincidentally I Ryan and I are little
daughter who will not allow you to make
an excuse you know their old daughter
yeah she will call you
if you throw a butt or you say well I
didn't know when we had to be there oh
so you're not taking ownership yeah yes
yeah
totally makes sense and if you it's
strangely like if you do it without the
but you know when you do it this
full-speed even if in your head you
believe but I mean let's face it man you
had it coming to you kind of did yeah
just keep it because that's not what
you're doing when you apologize that's
that's separate from the apology you
know it's like you're including this
stuff unwarranted stuff with your
apology don't do that give a good
apology in order is the worst thing is
is it's so obvious and it makes everyone
so mad oh yeah the receiving end of that
is so mad and you think that it's you
think that it's improving your position
yeah cuz I look I would look hey echo
I'm really sorry that you showed up to
record and I wasn't there and I didn't
let you know but yeah but I didn't
really I didn't remember texting you or
whatever like like but you know you
should have told me that you were
heading that's the last of whatever yeah
but you should have told me that we were
definitely recording cuz you didn't
really get back to me yeah like why
would I say that yeah all's I'm doing is
you know it's the funniest people always
treat me with a sports coach they tweet
me when a sports coach either takes
ownership or doesn't over yes not
overtly cuz some guys some sports coach
to say hey look I'm the coach I've made
some bad calls out there we're gonna get
back in the drawing room I'm gonna get
this thing fixed and if it goes man this
guy's awesome it's just so funny
everyone says this guy is awesome he's
taking ownership even people that aren't
even people will retweet something that
they people aren't saying he's taking
extreme ownership so I want to say oh
it's good to see a coach taking full
responsibility or whatever they'll use
their own word for it and then some
other knucklehead look will will say you
know um I am the coach and I am
responsible for the team but if I got
players that aren't gonna put out or in
the first quarter but yeah you know you
gotta carry out totally embarrassing for
and everyone says hey you might want to
learn how to take ownership yeah and
that's where people so it's so obvious
and yet we still do it and they still
throw out the butts we still want to
clarify our position yeah don't clarify
your position say sorry take on
that's it my wife will watch these uh
nobody called it the housewives one not
the show like the reality show ones you
know the whatever Housewives of where
and men riddled I think that's why she
watches it just to see the trainwreck I
think that's what I think is my
suspicion but men yeah they're all
arguing with each other and then you
know they're crying and then the one
will say they're just they'll say the
perfect example of the non-apology you
know every single time yeah man it's
like it hurts your heart to watch but
you kind of like and you kind of date
right I wonder I wonder if this is
because this is what happened with this
guy just I just figured it out right now
I really don't know but this is what I
think okay theoretically yes there was a
girl by relationship there was a what a
girl by relationship okay you know
boyfriend-girlfriend scenario you know
maybe this guy got drunk the bro the
brother bro whatever got drunk maybe hit
on the girl maybe something happened
maybe something did it oh and then it
was like hey sorry about what I did with
Christine last night I was super
hammered yes but I was super hammered
yeah exactly right and that's the big
one that's a big but in the apology you
know but you know we all had I remember
some once that time someone did I won't
go into it doesn't matter but it's a big
one yeah it's a big deal or it's a big
common one were wronged by a brother but
no it was my like parents friend okay
it's lady and she like she was talking
she was talking shit about my mom to my
dad uh-huh and I was there they're
hammered or whatever like some you know
things and she's like totally talking
she's like we're gonna talk about this
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it so I'm
like whenever I'm like a TI maybe 15 16
years old maybe
maybe 30 I don't know whatever but you
know a teenager I wasn't like a
three-year-old you know so I heard and I
knew what she was talking about it was
rude whose uncoolest son sat mm-hmm as
we say and some like cool all right go
home eight I tell my mom straight up so
I was like oh okay you know tells my dad
blahblah my dad tells the lady and the
lady of course is all like oh no you
know like I did this and you know so she
comes to me and she says sorry right
like sorry for this or
we hadn't you know we had a lot to drink
or whatever and all this stuff and I
remember feeling that like how is like
how does this make it better you know
when you're like but we had so I'm
thinking there and I didn't know
anything about drinking I don't know
what it made you sort of do I didn't
really know at that time so to me I was
like wait so wait when you drink like
you can do that kind of stuff or what
like what's the the deal and the the
apology just basically bounced off me
like bullets off a Superman or something
yeah you know I'll probably don't put
the butts on those things yes so that's
what happened with this guy that's what
I think possible but it is his
responsibility like you said to be like
hey I can't hold on to this thing you
know like what do you say how do you
psychologically reframing and kill that
lingering resentment thing is that it's
like a scar you have to - he's like
keeping it a wound you're cuter than him
at it
yeah and you got to be like that's just
a scar it's like sure our relationship
is different now just guard now deal but
man I got more important things to think
about or do whatever yeah if you can
pull that off you be good
move on